protesters took to the streets of Iran
again on Friday a day after a man was
put to death in the first execution over
recent anti-government protests
23 year old moxin shikari was hanged on
Thursday after observers described as a
show trial now activists are warning
that at least a dozen more Iranian
protesters are facing the same fate but
that didn't stop demonstrators from once
again voicing their opposition to the
regime
on Friday
they also took to the streets in other
cities like here in rutsa one day after
the execution of a 23 year old
demonstrator
others are also facing the death penalty
the most prominent rapper too much
salehi he was arrested nearly 40 days
ago
the musician was forced to make a
confession on state television a common
procedure in Iran
music can spread violence that was my
mistake I apologize to all of you and to
Society
on Friday afternoon we visited his uncle
in bochum in Germany where he runs a
copy shop naturally he's watched the
confession video he told us his reaction
a feeling of hatred of rage towards the
Islamic Republic
what I saw in this video is that too
much didn't speak voluntarily
the voice of too much was not one that
was full of energy and joy to express
his inner feelings
has not yet been convicted Dr Hamid
Hassan Lu has already been sentenced to
death he was convicted of participating
in the killing of the militia member at
a protest in the city of karage despite
his denials
the doctor and his wife were arrested
and beaten in the night according to his
brother who lives in Amsterdam
ENT
four of his dreams were broken during
torture
one of the ribs injured his lungs and
that caused internal bleeding
the radiologist had to be operated on
three times his brother told us shortly
after he woke up from the last operation
the 53 year old was sentenced to death
his wife was forced under torture to
testify against him
foreign
confession
his uncle is deeply concerned the family
hasn't been able to visit him since his
imprisonment
two cases out of many that highlight the
brutality with which those in power in
Iran are dealing with protesters
nevertheless many Iranians agree that
it's worth fighting for
voila let's speak to Daniella zaberry
she is an Iranian activist based in
Germany it's good to have you with us
here on DW news now in that report we've
just witnessed a number of testimonials
of a situation escalating uh in Iran
could you just bring us up to speed on
what activists and protesters have been
telling you from from Iran
they're telling me that the regime is
trying to
um frighten them but what we see in the
in the videos we get what we hear from
the people what we read from the
messages they send us is that their
courage is way greater than the than the
fear and that's what we're seeing also
in baluchista and zahadan happening two
days yesterday it was one day ago
um where the people of baluchistan and
zaidon went out of the streets again
went out to protest again even though
week by week they're getting slaughtered
by the regime and we see that in
Kurdistan we see that in Tehran we see
that everywhere in the country people
are not letting the regime
um frighten them but we are continuing
to see more heavy-handed tactics by the
government what does this mean for the
protesters living there
the government already announced that
there are getting harder and more brutal
against the protesters
um but you see it's about surviving for
the people in Iran it's about the bare
minimum it's about freedom and surviving
and because we know the people know that
they don't have a future with this
regime so that's why they still go on
the streets and protest and also they
know if they stop going out of the
streets then that's it then 18 000
people and more who got arrested will be
hanged just like mohsin shikari was
hanged a few days ago
now more Western sanctions are being
imposed on Iran will this make any
difference
I hope there will be full sanctions on
the regime this time because what we
have seen from the European Parliament
so far was like
um I don't know what it was it was like
for example the the morality police shot
was sanctionized in the first package
but um that's that's weird because the
gestures shot the morality police
doesn't have any money to be frozen they
also don't have money to enter the
European Union because they said we
won't let them enter anymore that it was
good to sanctionize them as a symbol but
it's for me it's better to also
sanctionize the whole revolutionary
guard the rogc responsible for so many
deaths not only Iran but in the whole
world it's for me it's important to
sanction the the regime the for example
the 272 politicians that voted for the
execution of all these um political
prisoners and that's what I what's what
I'm missing in the sanctions the
European Parliament is doing all the
time and that's what I'm hoping for for
the next sanctioned package that um the
the regime will be sanctionized okay
Danielle azeberry speaking to us in
Germany thank you so much for your time
thank you and the European Union is
considering further sanctions against
Iran over the executions our
correspondent Jack parrick in Brussels
has more on the likely form of those
measures
we've heard now from France and Ireland
to say that foreign ministers meeting in
Brussels at the start of next week are
going to sign off on Fresh sanctions
against Iran they could potentially
involve putting 20 people on a blacklist
of travel bans and asset freezes clearly
a lot of those people probably don't
actually have an intention to travel
into the European Union or perhaps their
assets here but it will be symbolic also
they'll do something similar to one
entity this is also over the protests
since the since the the death of Masha
amnini but also now since uh since an
Iranian gentleman as part of those
protests was um was executed in Iran
which the European Union
broadly is completely against the death
penalty anywhere and is very concerned
about this issue now we won't know the
exact details of what the sanctions that
are put on uh are until the foreign
ministers meet but we are pretty sure
that they that they will come into place
the question is what does this mean for
the broader context of the European
Union trying to pull Iran and the United
States back into the Iran nuclear deal
which is intended for to prevent Tehran
from Gaining access to a nuclear weapon
but which Iran means says it then wants
economic opening up to the rest of the
world and also the questions of its
relations to Russia because sanctions
have been placed on Iran for its sending
drone equipment to Russia to support its
invasion of Ukraine the big question is
is what power can sanctions have neither
Iran nor Russia for for that matter have
really changed their their path or their
their ways in the way that the Western
Powers would like them to no matter how
many sanctions have been put on
we're going to speak now to sieber who
is an Iranian German writer filmmaker
and activist her work is focused on
women's rights and religion in Iran
where she was born and raised it's it's
really great to have you on Welcome to
our show these death sentences are a
clear and brutal warning from the regime
what do you think is keeping the protest
going
you know thank you first of all for
having me today the day of the human
rights where
uh I get goosebumps thinking even about
it all the rights are being abused and
abusing violated by the Islamic Republic
and these people my people my Iranian
people go on the street and
risk everything to protect and to defend
the human rights and not just for
themselves but for the world
and
um what keeps people going on the street
is they have nothing to lose nothing
more to lose 70 of people in Iran are
facing hunger or live below or at the
poverty rate and they have not much to
lose and one thing is very very
important to understand having been born
as a third second fourth generation in
some cases
under a repressive regime like the
Islamic Republic
every day every every time you leave the
house every time somebody rings the bell
or makes a call to your phone you have
to fear that something terrible is going
to happen to you
the young people in my country have
become resilient nothing can scare them
anymore even death cannot scare them
anymore and they go out and they fight
for human rights you're saying that the
protesters have nothing more to lose
there it appears from what you're saying
that they're not going to back down it
appears the regime is not going to back
down either so with neither side giving
ground where do you expect this to all
go
it's a very ugly situation and the
regime exactly knows that they cannot
survive but they are still killing
people a drowning regime the only answer
they have is to kill people and they
want to in my opinion they want to gain
time to get their money and their
possessions out of the country we have
heard news in the past two days and we
have had news from right in the
beginning of the Revolution that the
high rank Islamic Republic leaders are
already
transporting out their possessions money
gold jewelry and so forth and their
families with private and secret fly
flights and now they talk to Venezuela
to get permission to live there with
their families and they try to get out
the positions I think they're just
trying to gain time this is this is the
absurdity of this current situation
these days like you said very rightly
everybody knows in the beginning it was
only us saying this regime is done this
time the revolution will win but now
everybody knows even they themselves
know that they are not going to come
back to power anymore but they are still
killing people it's just to gain time
it's just because
it's like a fly that you have killed and
it's fighting see but I I want to just
uh ask you finally about this execution
of Mosin shikari world leaders including
here in Germany have condemned his
execution they've announced fresh
sanctions against Iran do you think this
is going to make any kind of difference
at all
you know
I think whether it makes difference or
not at this point is not even important
but what is crucially important what is
crucially important is that these Thugs
and the leaders of the Islamic Republic
the criminals the murderers the child
Killers the rapers that they know that
they cannot make one single step without
the world seeing it and without the
world reacting to it and I think that's
what counts and I am grateful to every
country and its people and its leaders
and governments who actually do react to
every step that these criminals take
and we're grateful for your time that
was filmmaker and activist siba Shakib
thank you very much
thank you for giving the people in Iran
a voice and I
speaker thank you